i thought it was the most extraordinary  game and obviously  um i don't think i've ever seen an  england team play with such creativity  and flair and versatility and  just keep going like that you know the  way raheem sterling and harry kane just  kept their energy levels up uh  throughout the you know  120 minutes or uh whatever it was and it  was a it was a total  nail biter um i don't know about you but  i was  we conceded that goal early on and  then equalized and then ran on uh right  the way into extra time and  could have gone uh could have gone wrong  at any stage but it didn't and it was  just  euphoric absolutely extraordinary so i i  congratulate gareth southgate  and the whole team i thought they were  stunning  and obviously you know wishing them all  the very best for  for sunday  you